le manège royal de saint germain en laye
habité d'un esprit familial d'un père et
son fils stéphane bosco a tenu à
investir la galerie d'art pour rendre
hommage à son aïeul c'est l'exposition
de l'oeuvre une exposition rétrospective
de l'oeuvre de mon père puis à bosco qui
était peintre à saint germain en laye
qui a vécu toute sa vie à saint germain
en laye un qui est arrivé ici en 1931 en
tout environ 250 oeuvres sont exposées
de la peinture au couteau dont la série
la plus reconnue de l'artiste voilà d
une peinture caractéristiques de mon de
mon père sur les courses de chevaux qui
sont justement cette matière mise en
mouvement on voit bien le mouvement le
mouvement des choses durant leurs
courses c'est pas le sujet qui l'a qui
était le plus important dans son dans
son travail mais c'est bien la manière
dont il le traitait donc il a fait des
séries proviseur du lycée jean moulin au
chesnay stéphane bosco à monter
l'exposition en partenariat avec
plusieurs lycées professionnels toutes
ses parois que vous voyez la façon dont
ça a été pensé et où tout le cheminement
de l'exposition a été pensé par les
élèves et leurs professeurs on affine
maquettes dans les assemblées comme on
l'a fait au début de
du montage des meubles et après
on a commencé il ya deux jours à monter
les meubles ici c'est plutôt cool parce
qu'on voit les ce qu'on a créé pendant
plusieurs années enfin créer enfin
naître du coup c'est plutôt cool
satisfaisant la fiche a été pensé par
des élèves du lycée caraman à colombes
et les visuels par le lycée jean perrin
à saint-cyr-l'ecole déjà jeu là c'est
très beau alors finalisé parce que ça va
être vraiment pas mal ça va être bien en
fait de voir le résultat qu'est ce que
ça va donner en voyant du coup comment
on a installé les choses de venir voir
l'exposition montée sera quand elle sera
faite et du coup là normalement on aura
tous posé
[Musique]
la rétrospective d'une vie consacrée au
travail de mise en mouvement de la
matière à visiter dès ce vendredi 18
mars il faut redécouvrir cette cette
oeuvre qui est une oeuvre très original
qui a une très grande force il ya
j'avais deux artistes avec moi qu'ils
connaissaient pas le travail de mon père
qui sont deux jeunes artistes assez
connu dans le milieu parisien et quand
ils ont découvert cette heure ils ont
été enthousiastes l'exposition est en
accès libre jusqu'au 27 mars tous les
jours de 13h à 19h